i always find that there's um there's
something that i want to tell and
there's something that needs to be
changed and i want to be the one to help
change that
[Music]
thank you so much for being on my show
how are you happy
to be wonderful as you can see in the in
the gallery right now so no complaints
i love it you know i covet 19 is is
horrible it's horrific and it's
it's disturbing so many lives but i have
to say that i am thankful that i get to
have people like you on the show people
that are
so incredibly busy in the day today and
your response to my request is saying
well you know i'm in quarantine so we
might as well
because i have some time now so i want
to thank you first of all for
for being so generous with your time i
have so much to learn over these next 20
minutes so i'm really going to go fast
and i'm going to cram you with questions
because
there's just so there's just so many so
many things that i want that i want to
learn first of all
you know you i'm used to being on the
other side so i'm ready for
your questions i love it okay so so you
know you're a journalist by profession
now
you said multimedia journalists so you
cover you know agnostically all sorts of
different industries you you studied at
columbia university after serving
in in the elite intelligence units in in
israel
and you know been with cnn european
correspondent
now for channel 13 but you're also part
of the launch team
for i24 news right
that's all true yes amazing okay so i
got that right but
now it's your turn walk me back through
your journey how do you transition
from being a researcher in the
intelligence unit to being a journalist
right so
um it was actually a a very uh
it felt very natural the transition uh
if you think about it
um being in intelligence is all about
working with sources
and and writing reports and working with
a
tight-knit group of people and
what i actually realized i wanted to do
is continue that that
story order to shed light on various
issues
but on a wider basis so so journalism
was
a very very natural shift um from what i
was doing in in the military and in the
present prime minister's office um and
and i i
found myself i was i was debating you
know at 22 as
as most of us do in israel debating what
my
path in life will be and and i realized
that that storytelling and doing it
to wide audiences and you know
unearthing stories that i've never
heard about and have this this wow
element to them
but that more than 10 people can read
them because they're not top secret
um was was was what i was meant to do
and i started pursuing that root so
right after
my my studies i i worked for channel 2
news which was the
largest and still is that the largest
commercial news channel in israel
uh from there i had the amazing
opportunity to to be part of this
this media startup by i-24 news the
first ever
international multi-language uh channel
in in
israel i personally uh grew up my
upbringing was in london
so i had i had good english and this
channel was looking for
english native english speakers french
speakers and arabic speakers so i could
uh get this opportunity to become an
honor correspondent which i did for
uh about three years um and from then
shifted on to to life in in new york
as you mentioned my master's in colombia
journalism school
which was a ride in its own right um
a career in cnn yeah both new york and
in london
wow and now um i'm i'm usually based in
europe uh
right now quarantined in israel but this
has been a roller coaster and a
wonderful ride
i want to learn a little bit more about
your take on this idea that you're
unearthing stories within
the within the idf and the prime
minister's office you mentioned these
are stories that
are read by 10 people and now you're
shifting to unearthing stories that are
going to be watched by
by dozens of thousands if not hundreds
of thousands so so talk to me about that
shift
and i want to hear a little bit about
your take on the responsibility that you
hold
on unearthing these stories because like
we like we just talked
before we started i'm looking at the
work that you're doing and i'm saying
okay well i'm watching you
cover this story they you recovered a
story of eric trains in israel right
it with the protest back then and and i
watched that story and it was phenomenal
and then i kept thinking to myself like
wow these were amazing five minutes i
learned so much but there must be
another thousand minutes that i didn't
hear about right
and you hold the responsibility of
choosing which five minutes to show
so talk to me a little bit about that
responsibility all right so i'll take a
quick glimpse to behind the scenes
please what's happening really when you
do
either a print or digital story and
definitely in broadcast
um there are hours and hours of footage
usually you want you know
the more the merrier you want you want
to try and
make a deep dive into anything any story
you you encounter and one of the reasons
i became a journalist
was to you know every day learn new
things
and one day be in the kitchen with this
chef who's doing these creative things
and the other day
being in a terrific zone and and
covering
things that that happen that are
breaking news
and the the and the shift from cultural
to politics to
technology um to social issues is
so wide and so vast that i found it
fascinating and i still do
uh till this very day and so i love
doing this this deep dive into stories
but
you also have a limited amount of time a
limited amount of paper
um digital not so much but but today you
still have to limit the amount of words
that you uh
that you published no especially for my
generation you know
the the scrolling generation you know if
these are not
one minute bites it's hard to capture
attention and and it's almost there's a
and a conflict of interest that's saying
on one hand i want to capture the
attention with the click bait
on the other end i want to be
responsible and and and say truthful
information right
that's very true and what you want to do
is keep the essence of the stories so if
i'm covering
um a protest of migrants and asylum
seekers
or if i'm doing a story about this one
specific
artist i'm always looking at what the
what the messages that i'd like to
convey
what the other person what the story
that they're telling
um is and i've i've been very um
grateful and and thankful that i was
able to
tell some stories that actually create
change and
that that's that's what i would like to
do personally as a journalist
there's there's this um i guess stigma
of journalists being objective there's
always this
you know you can't put your your
feelings into things i i
it's no longer
when i study journalism and i personally
um
work that way i i always find that
there's um
there's something that i want to tell
and there's something that needs to be
changed and i want to be the one to help
change that
and especially working for cnn that was
uh
prominent when when we tell a story that
then
as you said hundreds and thousands of
people um can see
um we created change one of the stories
i did that i'm most proud of
is um highlighting holocaust survivors
that live in poverty
in the us um it's it's a very well-known
well-covered
issue in israel being treated
but in in the united states of america
you know the
um empire of capitalism uh if you're
poor you're poor and you you need to you
know
lift yourself up but when we're talking
about holocaust survivors
most of them over um 80 85 years old
this this was surprising to me that they
have no um
structure and no
some kind of institution that is taking
care of them from the
state from the federal level and after
doing this story
we've received multiple and multiple
um individuals calls from individuals
from
organizations from non-profits who said
i want to
lend a hand i want to help can you
connect me to these individuals
i want to do something about this so
that's just one example of how you
and i spent hours and hours with these
people but the essence was to tell their
very specific story in order to get them
help or
tell another stories awareness or tell
another story that would
create some kind of initiative um these
are all things that i'm very passionate
about
and how do you even uncover these
stories so you know growing up as an
israeli
in tel aviv and now in the bay area i
you know i have family that that
perished in the holocaust and
and i'm i'm very i'm very versed in you
know the history of it but
i never even stopped to think that yes
in the u.s also we have
holocaust survivors that might not be
are that that don't have the structure
in this capitalist society that israel
provides
or is aiming to provide currently to to
hawk survivors how do you go about
unearthing these stories and
really really understanding their value
because i mean part of the part of the
idea here is that you're unearthing
things that are not
mainstream right right and i was
actually very fortunate to be the
outsider when i was working in the cnn
newsroom in
in um in new york specifically i was the
only israeli
actually i was the only foreigner
everyone that was was american and our
specific department was about
50 60 people and that actually allowed
me to be
um you know sort of the the one that
brings in
these alternative stories things that
others didn't
uh look at and it was it was actually an
amazing time was the height of the uh uh
hillary clinton and and donald trump
campaigns
um and there was a lot of um
focus on xenophobia on the other
on on immigrants on
on asylum seekers and
in addition to that being a fascinating
topic for me i i
also found myself bringing years that
um we're different from the the regular
mindset and
because um cnn allowed me this amazing
opportunity to just
hear the camera go out and you know
explore
boise idaho and baton rouge louisiana
and all these places i've never heard of
and suddenly had this opportunity to
cover the campaigns there
and how people were reacting um there
was the this whole issue
with north korea obviously and then we
started um
interviewing north korean um asylum
seekers in the us wow which was
fascinating and it was only because i
think
i was the outsider that i was looking
for these outsider stories
um so that was a great opportunity
that's that's just incredible and
i mean are there specific things that
you're particularly excited about as you
go about
is it the is it the filming of it the
interviewing the research in the
computer
or is it the you know the
post-production helping the editors put
the story together
which part of it are you most excited oh
that's like
choosing between mom and dad um it
well especially in past couple of years
when i've been a
really just a one-woman band i've been
the
the correspondent the photographer the
um
researcher the producer it's um
unfortunately unfortunately only me
um so so i'll give you an example um we
we were in paris when the notre dame um
caught on fire and obviously was a
historic and devastating moment
and at that point obviously it's just me
by chance i was with my tripod and
camera with me
and what i needed to do at that moment
when working news and i'm on air all the
time i had to
do this combination of filming myself
reaching out and asking people and the
the police
women and men that were there what was
going on interviewing
um being in touch with the control room
these are all things that the
producer oh my god it does the
researcher does
and the uh reporter usually do
thankfully my husband was there to help
me carry around the tripod here and
there
but but um most of these things i do by
myself and i
i love it there's a lot of adrenaline
but i also will admit it's it's a
it's a big challenge sometimes it's you
know um
i i i i'm so exhausted by the end of the
day that uh i
i'm asking myself why do i do this um
but then
the following day comes and and there's
another story to cover to me it sounds
like you're ready to transition from
this to running the control room for a
nasa
uh for nasa launch because it doesn't
sound too different at this point those
two things
just just give me the control pad i'll
take care of everything how long does it
take
from the moment that you are you
understand that there is some potential
for something
yeah there might be something in
arkansas that we might want to cover
this is interesting to the moment where
it actually gets aired
to millions of viewers on cnn and and
you get the message across how long does
that process take
it really depends so if you're talking
about cnn again
it's uh it's a huge well-oiled machine
they have the resources to just say even
we're not sure there's a story there but
here
are plane tickets or a train ride or a
car or
or the the accommodation that you need
right um
just there's a story there um there was
one sort of murder mystery i did
driving for for like five days through
um
it was connecticut massachusetts um
i think i think rhoda a few states
there in the uh northeastern part of the
us
just to try and chase a story and see if
if there's there's
bulk and and anything that we can
actually create
content from so so it really depends and
this was from
from one day to the next just shakha you
ready uh
on tuesday to to take the car and just
go on a road trip
uh around these states to see if there's
a story others
um you know it might take time if we
have we have time to plan ahead and
and see in advance if we can do one
story or another
then we we do the planning most of the
time it's
it's not even from one day to the next
now with with channel 13
as you know in israel everything's last
minute and
and we can we can sometimes decide from
one hour to the next that i'm
on this flight to to germany to cover a
story or
incredible wherever i need to be across
europe it sounds exhausting and
exhilarating at the same time and
that's no no that's just incredible and
you know looking down
at how you're how you're now you know
operating in these you operate in
different places
and i'm really curious to hear your take
on the
transition of journalism and to the
different generations and i'm looking at
you know i'm even looking at my nieces
who are you know who are you know
now a few days old uh three years and
six years old and the way that they're
consuming information not necessarily
news but any information is drastically
different
than the way that i'm even consuming it
and so
i'd love to hear a little bit about your
take on how journalism is changing
and adapting to the younger generations
and i believe you also you asked this
question
to to the person who ran bbc news right
and and so i'm especially curious to
hear your answer
well you did your research um i'm
speaking to a journalist i had to
prepare a little bit
right very true i'm very impressed um so
um you know the phrase from pixar's
ratatouille
everyone can be a chef or everyone can
be a cook
um these days i feel like everyone can
be a journalist
you need you need the basic tools and
obviously some experience
but with the platforms that exist today
to reach
everyone and anyone at any time
it's also you know the danger and we can
spend hours talking about misinformation
and disinformation but
but it's also an amazing opportunity
to to spread stories and and reach so
many people
um so very quickly and i i look at
myself today i can see news
mostly from social media and i'm not
talking only about
um you know facebook or or
places where you can add a lot of text
and explain the story
instagram today um yes twit uh um
even tick tocks these days uh you can
learn
so much from these platforms in terms of
um
just even getting a new initiative or an
inspiration from seeing someone
doing anything and saying hey that's new
or i've never heard or seen anyone do
that thing before or ask those questions
before
and and want to do a story from that or
get information from that
and i think anyone who's seriously in
news has
um presence in all of these uh platforms
um because that's where we
get the news and this is a way to spread
news as well so
without a doubt you know um social media
tv still exists as as does radio
i can't say that much about print but
but everything that has to do with with
social media today and and the platforms
know it
facebook amazon apple google
the all the big digital giants um that
they know that that
that's where people consume their their
news and their information
and that that's what they do they they
are now putting more and more focus on
right
right misinformation and become a
truthful justifiable news platform right
so i agree i mean
we can talk for hours about the the
dangers of misinformation and fake news
that come with
the democratization of of dissemination
of information but what i'm especially
curious is
do you believe that 10 years or 15 years
from now
we will need reporters to be in front of
the notre dame
and in case something happens or is it
enough
that we'll have people holding their
whatever device they'll use if it won't
be already in our glasses
and and talk while they're watching do
is there's still room for
in-field journalism in 10 15 years
if i become a journalist simply by the
virtue of me having a phone
i actually thought that you were about
to ask me um
[Music]
um and and for that i have a very quick
answer but so no no let's start with
because your question is more
interesting so
just start with the robots one um well
with robots what we can see today is
that
even with the the basic levels of ai
that we have today
it's it's not giving us stories when i
when i go to youtube and even if you if
you make it better and
the aggregation of information will be
better then you won't get the levels of
depth and investigation that you want
from what currently ai can do and i
don't see that
improving in 10 years we can talk about
50 but but
to your to answer your question um i
i i think that yes anyone can become a
journalist but you have to have the um
um i think the still the it's all about
trust so you have to have
the back the backing and the uh the
support of some kind of system
that people trust so you can be an
individual and
and stop reporting and if what you are
unveiling
is is found to be truthful interesting
new you know all the basics and the
fundamentals of of news
of course you you can become a
journalist there's it's all about
practice and experience of how to ask
the right questions and how to address
you need that but very much so in
journalism it says
on job training and i'm saying that
someone who is a master's in journalism
most of what i do write today is not
from school it's from
it's from being in the field and and and
i think yes
an individual can do that but it's it's
obviously helpful when you have
the new york times or or the new yorker
or the what
between you as as um not only a support
system but as a way of other
others to trust you wow so i think i
think in 10 years
that would still be the case this was
inspiring and i learned so much over
these past 20 minutes i want to thank
you again for being so generous with
your time
before we finish i have to ask you the
most important question
three words that you would use to
describe yourself right so i
i thought very hard on on that question
because it's very very difficult
so i guess the the first which is a new
word for me would be
mother um congratulations
six month old sunshine um so and it's
not only mother it's if i cheat a bit
it's being a
family person a family woman because
it's it's my
my dear dear husband my partner and my
son who are now
definitely defining myself and my life
um the second word would be storyteller
and i don't need to uh
elaborate on that i think we've done
that uh for 20 minutes now
um and uh the third who
what was the third i think it's it's
difficult because
it's trying to describe myself but of
course it could be
uh i don't want to cheat it could be um
anything from being
uh i'd let you cheat a little bit uh
okay thank you
so anything from being
multi-disciplinary to
um just being honest uh an honest person
um sometimes it's good and sometimes
it's a bit bad
um but but yeah i guess that described
the best
thank you very very much this was
inspiring uh enjoy the quarantine i see
that
throughout throughout our throughout the
filming of this episode it got dark over
there so
in that case but thank you very very
much
and and i look forward to continue
seeing the stories that you unfold
thank you so much
you